big big news with regard to possibly
your health care years of chastising
Obamacare but not coming together with a
coherent alternative of their own
Republicans have now put forth the
American Health Care Act it is an
absolute and completely atrocious
proposal and I'm going to tell you
exactly why here is the big announcement
from Paul Ryan afternoon this is the
American Health Care Act it's been a
long time in coming write this bill the
American Health Care Act
it keeps our promise to repeal and
replace Obamacare
it delivers relief to Americans fed up
with skyrocketing premiums and fewer
choices it moves us away from the broken
status quo toward a better patient
centered system it actually does quite
the opposite let's start with the list
of what is in the American Health Care
Act the list of American Health Care Act
provisions that list which I will put up
on the screen for you begins with states
would retain the option of running
Obamacare like exchanges and Medicaid
expansion retain the option being the
key word there the uninsured are
penalized under this system but in a
very different way than under the
Affordable Care Act tax breaks for
employer sponsored coverage are capped
people can stay on their parents plans
until age 26 discrimination based on
pre-existing conditions is prohibited
and insurers are required to cover
mental health and substance abuse
so based only on what I've told you so
far if you hated Obamacare you should
sort of not like this either because
it's a lot of the same stuff but of
course anything branded as Trump care or
passed under Trump Trump is will go with
it even if it has many many similarities
to the Affordable Care Act but here's
the really disastrous part this
so-called American Health Care Act tries
to keep many parts of Obamacare which
understandably a lot of those provisions
are really popular with Americans I
understand why Republicans
would actually try to keep some of these
provisions but it removes the aspects of
Obamacare that allow it to actually
function okay here's list number two
which is Obamacare provisions that are
gone from let's just call it Trump care
now for lack of a better term
the mandates are gone new taxes are gone
higher taxes on the rich to cover the
costs are gone premium subsidies as
outlined in Obamacare are gone Medicaid
guarantees are gone and reasonable caps
on what companies can charge older
people are gone this is why this
combination of provisions doesn't work
the new Republican plan gets rid of
individual and employer mandates this
was sort of the central republican
critique of obamacare but it's actually
the thing that keeps it functioning if
you want health care to be affordable
for everyone and cover people with
pre-existing conditions you've got to
spread out the risk among the largest
pool of people possible this is called
economies of scale the more people you
have paying in the cheaper it will be on
average for each individual customer and
I hate that I'm even calling these
people customers but that's what they
are in a fourth prop for-profit health
insurance system the Republican plan
would do away with the fine for not
having insurance and replace it with a
fee that you pay to the insurance
companies and you pay it you don't pay
it on an ongoing basis think about the
absurdity of that instead of paying the
penalty to the government you're paying
the penalty for not having insurance to
the for-profit health insurance company
and you only have to pay that penalty
for one year so there is a penalty for
being uninsured but the Republicans
backing the plan say it's okay because
you're paying it to a private for-profit
insurance company what's this going to
do this will incentivize young people
and healthier people not to buy
insurance until they're sick which makes
insurance more expensive by reducing the
sort of average health level of people
who have insurance
altogether this is going to make it so
that you have number one fewer people
paying into the market and of the people
who are paying in more of them will be
sicker
healthy that fundamentally makes
premiums increase and it could
potentially make the healthcare market
implode this is why the Affordable Care
Act has the mandate it's not because of
big bad government looking to
nanny-state people it's math the
Affordable Care Act is also financed in
large part by taxes on the wealthiest
Americans this bill would repeal those
taxes people making over a million
dollars a year would get an average of a
fifty thousand dollar tax cut the richer
you are the bigger your tax cut people
in the top 0.1% would get an average tax
cut of about two hundred thousand
dollars also and this is extra dangerous
this new bill the American Health Care
Act it would repeal the Medicaid taxes
which are individually singularly
responsible for keeping the Medicaid
trust fund afloat and this is dangerous
Pat because Republicans could defund
Medicaid intentionally so that then it
doesn't work as well and then use it as
a justification to get rid of it
altogether hey listen we should get rid
of Medicaid it's not working well well
it's not working well because you
defunded it and Republicans are trying
to market this bill is so much better
than Obamacare because this bill is only
66 pages long and writing out that
Obamacare was somewhere between 1,000
and 2,000 pages you saw a Sean Spicer at
a recent press conference yeah we
compared the paper but of the 66 pages
in this new American Health Care Act
seven of them have to do with states
being allowed to take away Medicare
coverage from lottery winners so
Medicare or Medicaid Medicaid yeah that
fluff piece get in there it's the entire
the number of pages in the bill tells us
anything objectively about whether it's
good or bad is so it's just it's
pandering and it's pandering to people
who want government doing nothing and
when you actually ask serious questions
like at yesterday's press conference one
of Paul Ryan's buddies this guy right
over here with the glasses I actually
forget his name he was asked what will
this do to the number of people who
actually have coverage there's two and a
half years presumably during which this
is all rolled in so what would happen in
2020 and the guy with the glasses whose
name is escaping me because he's such a
despicable guy he said something like
hey we have no way to predict what's
going to happen
20 that's 2.5 years away what kind of an
answer is that that it's just not an
answer to the question that was asked
and fundamentally look at what the bill
does and the last thing I want to talk
about is the subsidies income based
subsidies go away with Obamacare the
less money you make the bigger subsidy
you get because thinking clearly here
when you have less money it's harder to
afford health insurance the aah a the
American Health Care Act would instead
put in place a an age based tax credit
meaning number one the older you are the
more subsidy you get which is kind of
counterintuitive in a way because on
average the older people are the more
money they have the less need they have
for money to pay for their health
insurance and the entire tax credit
thing Pat is a shout out of sorts it's
pandering to the lower my taxes crowd
because by doing it as a tax credit
instead of as a subsidy you can't out we
cut people's taxes of course you're
doing it in a way that's
self-destructive and counterproductive I
really wonder if this is even going to
pass though because it seems to be
dividing even Republicans there seems to
be a lot of infighting at this point yep
because some are considering this to be
another entitlement kind of like
Obamacare light and others are going to
be angry that their constituents are
going to lose the Medicaid expansion so
there could be a lot of infighting here
I don't know if Donald Trump is going to
continue to own this if it gets more
controversial yeah if it's debated just
as the Affordable Care Act was so we'll
see what the future of this is like last
thing I want to talk about the
Republican plan would also prevent
Planned Parenthood from getting Medicaid
reimbursements for a year this has
nothing to do with making health care
more affordable in fact it would do
quite the opposite it's pandering to
religious conservatives and social
conservatives it is absolutely and
utterly insane and what's going on is
now that the Republicans actually can
repeal Obamacare before they could try
to repeal it in the house didn't matter
Obama was going to veto it now that they
actually can repeal it many of them are
saying wait a second millions of people
will lose coverage how is that going to
impact my reelection chances we will see
what ultimately happens here I predict
that some trumpets anything that Trump
signs his name to no matter what it is
they will consider a major
accomplishment send me your thoughts
about this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman